we have a new MCU movie that is a new
Ant-Man movie and before we talk about
that I want to give some love to the
sponsor of this video this video is
brought to you by nordvpn nordvpn's the
digital sword shield and armor that
looks to protect you good folks protect
you from the CD cyber criminal
underworld known as well the internet
nord's threat protection blocks malware
written websites scans downloaded files
for viruses but you don't even have to
be out there for trouble to find you
don't have to go on any websites that
might give you malware ever used a
public Wi-Fi at a restaurant coffee shop
airport I do every time that means I'm
exposed if you ever do it you are
exposed escalation is a thing they've
gotten really good at it at this point
they just want your information they
don't care what it does to you so
protect yourself click the link below go
to nordvpn.com Johns and with the
purchase of a two-year plan you get one
additional month for free and since it's
nord's 11th birthday they're giving you
one additional Mystery Gift that's right
they're giving you a gift for their
birthday and it's all back by nord's
30-day money-back guarantee and now we
talk about the movie that had a really
great song choice for the trailer this
song was in my head for about two months
foreign
so Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum manias
essentially the new Journey to the
Center of the Earth movie that takes
place in the MCU he said jokingly but
only half the MCU Quantum realm is not
bare it's not Baron it's not nothing
there's actually a whole civilization
down there and Michelle Pfeiffer's
character was running and gunning for 30
years while she was down there though a
few hours in the quantum realm was five
years to us so was she down there for 30
years or was she down there for 30 hours
to her I don't know we're on a new
adventure Scott Lang's daughter's like
hey I whipped up this device I can
communicate with the quantum realm in my
garage they all get sucked down into the
quantum realm Kang is there is going to
be a problem and I need to try to get
out of there unscathed okay what I liked
about this movie is very simple it's the
thing we all wanted to be awesome but
figured would be awesome because anyone
who bets against Jonathan Majors is not
playing the odds Jonathan Majors as Kang
was [__] epic I don't mind saying he
completely made the movie the movie has
some fun in there absolutely but it's
the basic MCU talking points you have
after you see an MCU film he showed up
to work and showed up he did not only
that a standout MCU villain just in the
entirety of the MCU which is great not
only for this film but the MCU going
forward because it's been like hey who's
the new Thanos all right Jonathan Majors
as king we saw a glimpse of a variant of
him at the end of Loki but we haven't
actually seen him one of the things I
liked about Jonathan majors in this
movie as Kang is he didn't fall into the
MCU trap that a lot of other characters
in this movie fall into a lot of other
characters and a lot of other MCU movies
fall into MCU movies in general fall
into and that's the clippiness the mcu's
overwhelming urge to make every moment a
funny moment have everyone have a snarky
clippy response like everyone needs to
be funny even when it's out of
characters not everybody has to be funny
have your comic relief character and
that's totally fine but when the shit's
going down don't compromise it with
humor and this movie does do that but
not when Kang is on screen when Jonathan
Matrix is on screens like everyone like
just stand back let him work which was a
great call he's engaging as hell he's
threatening you know he will follow
through on his threats he's a badass
villain by any metric also I will say
some of the cgis actually really good in
terms of setting an atmosphere for a
movie that's essentially borrowing from
Journey to the Center of the Earth Tron
legacy absolutely in here a little bit
of Mad Max Beyond Thunderdome as well I
thought the world visually aesthetically
speaking I thought it was fun but some
of the fighting I noticed like there's
when everything was CGI on screen and
CGI things were fighting other CGI
things it's like the camera knew how to
stay on it because it's well it's not a
camera but there are some scenes where
live action people are fighting and it's
really choppy shaky cam at times
couldn't believe it it's like shaky cam
is the trend we never want to come back
but like all Trends it's coming back and
I'm seeing more of it again let's not
the three acts of this film feel like
three different movies sometimes like
the First Act was the most interesting
we get to this world it's more
interesting than I thought it would be
and that's because it didn't feel like
an MCU movie in terms of
the MCU vernacular the way people talk
their clippiness it wasn't really there
yeah then the ant family gets this
McGuffin in which they can all
understand everyone which means we can
understand everyone and after that a
large number of these Quantum realm life
forms now talk with that cookie cutter
MCU sass has been plaguing the MCU for
years things like that make me feel like
the mcu's a parody of itself is can we
just have that die at Thor 11 Thunder I
get it I'm not as young as I used to be
I'm not as connected maybe I have that
old man energy going along a young folk
that might be watching this do you enjoy
that it's actually a real question I am
curious like what's the demographic
they're going for so the First Act
starts out interesting it starts to drop
because of that second act is when we
get a lot more Kang like that the third
Act is
batshit I am flipping a coin as to which
movie had more [__] going on for the
last act just on screen in general this
or the last Act of Aquaman it's a lot
going on if for Ant-Man it feels a
little weird to me granted ant-man's
really the thing that
dabbled into the quantum realm because
well he's the character with the
shrinking Tack and so why not I get it
it makes sense but in terms of this
Grand scope Adventure it's like Scott
Lang Ant-Man that was never what I liked
about him I like the smaller personal
story of the first movie having him come
in for a bigger fight as part of an
ensemble with the Avengers that was fun
that works but this movie was a lot more
than Ant-Man ever needed to be there are
more characters in this movie than there
ever have been in an Ant-Man movie in
terms of protagonist Scott Lang's
character the Ant-Man vibe that blue
collar everyday man who got to be a hero
regardless of the odds it gets lost
under the weight of this whole enormous
story to be fair they come close to
capturing something special with Scott
Lang's Arc but this isn't horseshoes or
grenades close isn't there which is fine
if you choose to see the movie how I
choose to see the movie which is Kang
the Conqueror versus the ant fan so I
don't give a [__] this movie worked for
me when it was Kang also modox in it
it's not a sport spoiler is it everyone
like I knew Modoc was in it and I don't
have Twitter if I knew about it I feel
like most people knew about that if you
feel like that's a spoiler if you're a
big Modoc fan don't get your hopes up he
sucks ass in this movie I've never been
a Modoc Super Fan myself like modoc's
one of those characters that's bobbed
and weaved in and out or through Marvel
stories that I've known but I was never
like oh modoc's badass I need to see
Modoc in a movie and if this is Modoc in
a movie no one should ever think that he
was bad CGI face especially in contrast
with like I said the setting looked
great so bad Modoc CGI face just looks
worse the whole time I was like Modoc is
silly at best but worse than that and
why is he even here it doesn't need to
be here look in the end Ant-Man and the
WASP Quantum Mania it was all right it
had some fun Parts Jonathan Majors as
Kang was great made the film entirely I
just wish the film he was in as a whole
was better I feel like this is a better
time if you're drunk yeah no it's a
Quantum party alright so Ant-Man in the
WASP Quantum Mania have you seen it what
did you think about it it's a little
early for that question it'll only be
early for about three days though and
then every day after that it's a valid
question so whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to say more
[Music]